The trailer for director Nia DaCosta's Candyman,
a "spiritual sequel" to the 1992 horror classic
of the same name, has finally been released
online, and it promises plenty of cerebral
thrills of the kind that we've come to associate
with producer and co-writer Jordan Peele - not
to mention an inspired take on a story that
sent chills down the spines of horror fans
three decades ago.
These are just a few things that may have
slipped by you in that excellent new trailer.
Yahya Abdul-Mateen II portrays Anthony McCoy,
who moves into the neighborhood near Chicago's
Cabrini-Green housing projects, the area which
was once terrorized by Daniel Robitaille - that's
the titular hook-wielding specter's real name,
by the way.
These days, though, it looks a little different;
the area has become near-completely gentrified,
with most of the buildings comprising the
old housing projects having been demolished.
In their place are ritzy high-rises, houses,
shops, and art museums - the latter of which
may be what drew McCoy to the area.
McCoy, you see, is an artist, just like Robitaille
himself; apparently, he's a pretty talented
one, as the trailer implies that it doesn't
take him long to score an exhibit in his new
neighborhood.
It looks like Candyman will see McCoy becoming
just a wee bit obsessed with Robitaille's
legend, which is the focus of the exhibit.
Hell, it even includes an arrangement of mirrors.
"The mirror invites you to summon him."
The spot reveals that McCoy begins to identify
with Robitaille just a bit too closely, and
their shared profession raises the question
of how else they might be connected.
Is McCoy a descendant of Candyman?
Or even the reincarnation of the doomed artist?
In the original film, it was heavily implied
that Helen may have been Caroline Sullivan,
Robitaille's lover, reincarnated.
It's not clear what the connection is - but
it seems certain that there is one.
"Once a troubled corner of Chicago, but the
area that was home to the Cabrini-Green housing
projects has changed pretty drastically over
the years.”
The fact of Cabrini-Green's gentrification
is a fascinating aspect of this new Candyman's
plot, and one which producer and co-writer
Jordan Peele is sure to mine for a truckload
of thematic resonance.
Interestingly, though, the trailer makes it
plain that while the area has undergone quite
the "revitalization," its past isn't completely
buried; fragments of it remain, such as the
old, boarded up buildings where McCoy first
encounters William Burke - played by Colman
Domingo - who appears to be a long-time resident.
The idea here seems to be that a troubled,
violent past can never truly be buried...
not even by pricey condos and upscale restaurants.
Hey - the truth hurts…
literally.
"Shh!
Shh…
Don't.
Don't say that."
Near the spot's end, as it really starts to
pick up steam with the lightning-quick edits
and disturbing imagery, a voice creeps in
on the soundtrack - and if you're a fan of
the original movie, you recognized it immediately.
"I am the writing on the wall.
The sweet smell of blood.
Be... my victim."
Yep, it's the man himself: that's the voice
of Tony Todd, whose restrained yet intense
performance made Candyman such a frightening
presence in the 1992 flick.
For a good chunk of the time the film was
in production, it was thought that Abdul-Mateen
would be replacing Todd as Candyman; obviously,
this isn't the case, but DaCosta isn't particularly
keen to let us know just what the case is,
or exactly how large a part Todd will have
in the new film.
In March 2019, the director told Collider:
"It's been slightly misreported.
I can't say what's happening in the film because
we want it to be a surprise, but [Abdul-Mateen
is] not replacing Tony Todd.
That's been reported, and I was just like,
'I don't know what to say about this.
This is not right.'"
Since we never see Candyman's face in the
trailer - only his bloody hook - we can't
say with certainty that Todd will reprise
his role.
But he is definitely involved - and that can
only be a good thing.
We'll see just what Peele, DaCosta, and company
have cooked up for us when Candyman hits the
big screen on June 12, 2020.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.